[Música]
Nicolás Maduro fue recibido con honores
en Brasil una visita que el presidente
brasileño calificó como el inicio del
regreso de su homólogo venezolano al
plano regional hace ocho años que el
líder chavista no visitaba a su antiguo
Aliado y llega para una cumbre de
líderes sudamericanos
Cristina Fernández arremete contra la
justicia Argentina la vicepresidenta del
país crítico la decisión de un fiscal de
solicitar que el proceso abierto por el
atentado en su contra sea elevado a
juicio oral la mandataria calificó el
acto como impunidad Tenemos reporte
cuando eran a 14 años de prisión al
expresidente de El Salvador Mauricio
Funes el ex mandatario fue hallado
culpable por haber facilitado una tregua
con las pandillas durante su gobierno
unas vive en Nicaragua y su juicio se
llevó a cabo en su ausencia Tenemos
reporte desde San Salvador
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Brasil el presidente Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva recibió a su homólogo
venezolano Nicolás maduro y ambos
declararon el pleno restablecimiento de
sus relaciones diplomáticas rotas
durante la administración de Jair
bolsonaro ambos mandatarios sostuvieron
su primer encuentro bilateral previo a
la llegada de 10 presidentes
suramericanos a Brasilia en un encuentro
clave con el que el presidente brasileño
quiere relanzarla una sur el informe es
de Juan Armando rojas
una nueva era en las relaciones entre
Venezuela y Brasil con la llegada del
presidente Nicolás Maduro Brasilia y el
encuentro con su homólogo Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva las relaciones
diplomáticas comienzan a normalizarse la
presencia de maduro en Brasil se da
Después de que el anterior gobierno del
derechista Jair bolsonaro le prohibiera
el ingreso a ese país en 2019 tras
reconocer a Juan guaidó como presidente
interino de Venezuela
el encuentro transcurrió en medio de
expresiones amistosas de parte y parte
después de ocho años el presidente
maduro regresa a Brasil
y hemos
recuperado el derecho de hacer política
y de sostener relaciones bilaterales
maduro quien recordó que el anterior
administración de Brasil había cerrado
todos los canales diplomáticos con
Caracas dio por reactivadas estas
relaciones a todo nivel
y en esa nueva época debe corresponder
entonces la construcción de un nuevo
mapa de cooperación de trabajo conjunto
que abarque todas las áreas
todas las áreas de la economía
todas las áreas del comercio
la educación la salud la cultura la
agricultura los presidentes de diez
países de Suramérica se reúnen Este
martes en Brasilia convocados por el
presidente Lula como parte de una
iniciativa para relanzar la unión de
Naciones suramericanas unasur debilitada
tras la victoria de los gobiernos de
derecha en la región Y que ahora
regresaría con el retorno de los
mandatarios de izquierda ahora vamos a
hasta Argentina este lunes la
vicepresidenta Cristina Fernández de
kirchner volvió a cargar contra el poder
judicial del país en esta oportunidad
por una decisión Del fiscal que lleva el
caso por el atentado en su contra el
pasado primero de septiembre de enviar a
juicio oral a las tres personas
detenidas dentro de la causa y no
continuar investigando sus denuncias
sobre
nexos con figuras políticas los detalles
con nuestro corresponsal en Buenos Aires
natalio cosoy el fiscal Carlos rivolo a
cargo de la investigación por el intento
de homicidio contra la vicepresidenta
Cristina Fernández de kirchner solicitó
la elevación del caso a juicio oral
pidió allí que Fernando sabad Montiel
quien gatilló el arma y los otros
implicados Brenda uliarte y Nicolás
carrizo se han acusados por tentativa de
homicidio tras conocerse la noticia la
vicepresidenta publicó una carta en sus
redes sociales una carta que remata con
la frase me quieren presa o muerta allí
sostiene y cito textual que hay un
intento evidente y desesperado por
evitar hallar la posible participación
de terceros financistas e instigadores y
la vicepresidenta sostiene en la carta
que hay líneas de investigación Que para
ella podrían vincular a figuras de la
oposición con este intento de homicidio
y segura que es apresurado el envío a
juicio oral sin seguir explorando esas
líneas pero para el fiscal rivolo no hay
elementos que sustenten la idea de
financiamiento político en este intento
de homicidio en El Salvador el
expresidente Mauricio Funes fue
condenado a 14 años de prisión por las
treguas que hizo con las pandillas
durante su gobierno entre 2012 y 2014 en
total son ocho años por el cargo de
agrupación ilícita y seis años por
incumplimiento de deberes los detalles
los tiene desde San Salvador nuestro
corresponsal Vladimir Chamorro
el expresidente Mauricio Funes recibió
de parte de un tribunal capitalino una
sentencia de 14 años de prisión por los
delitos de agrupaciones ilícitas e
incumplimiento de deberes el exministro
de justicia y seguridad pública David
Munguía payés fue condenado también a 18
años de cárcel por dichos delitos Además
del de actos arbitrarios Funes y Munguía
palés Fueron acusados por la fiscalía de
avalar en el 2012 las negociaciones
entre las pandillas para acordar una
supuesta reducción de los homicidios a
cambio de beneficios para los cabecillas
de la Mara Salvatrucha y el barrio 18
que se encontraban recluidos en centros
penitenciarios durante su gestión entre
ellos el traslado a centros penales de
menor seguridad y reuniones con otros
miembros de la estructura que estaban
fuera de las cárceles la representación
fiscal se mostró satisfecha con el fallo
del caso tregua y lo concedieron
consideró de histórico por tratarse de
un expresidente de la República Funes
estuvo en la presidencia entre 2009 y
2014 actualmente vive en Nicaragua tras
haber obtenido la nacionalidad de ese
país en cambio Munguía país se encuentra
en prisión debido a estas acusaciones
ambos funcionarios han negado
reiteradamente los cargos que se le
imputan Y esperan que o esperan que
presenten una apelación a la resolución
del juez una publicación del periódico
digital El Faro de 2020 sugiere que
también el actual gobierno del
presidente bukele sostuvo negociaciones
con las principales pandillas del país
dentro de penales de máxima seguridad a
fin de mantener el histórico desplome
del número de homicidios reportado en su
gestión sin embargo hasta ahora no se
conoce si existe una línea de
investigación al respecto por parte de
la fiscalía la inseguridad alimentaria
aguda podría aumentar en 22 países según
el más reciente informe de la
organización de la ONU para la
agricultura y la alimentación y el
programa mundial de alimentos en América
Latina Haití continúa en el nivel de
alerta de hambre más alto mientras que
El Salvador Guatemala Honduras y
Nicaragua fueron incluidos como puntos
críticos por las precarias condiciones
de alimentación Andrés triviño tiene los
detalles
el hambre aumentó un 30% desde 2019 en
América Latina así lo reveló el más
reciente informe de la Organización de
las Naciones Unidas para la alimentación
y la agricultura FAO la pandemia del
covid-19 la crisis climática y la guerra
en Ucrania son las principales causas si
hablamos de números de América Latina y
el Caribe estamos hablando de 56
millones de personas que se encuentran
en situación de hambre más de 130
millones mínimamente que no se alimentan
bien son datos graves Haití es el
momento más dramático que existe en
América Latina y el Caribe a nivel
mundial el informe estima que más de 228
millones de personas padecen de hambre y
añadió a 22 países dentro de la
situación alimentaria más grave dentro
de los cuales se encuentran Haití
burkina faso y Mali estos lugares tienen
un alto número de personas que enfrentan
inseguridad alimentaria aguda crítica
junto con factores que empeoran y que se
esperan se intensifiquen aún más Durante
los próximos seis meses amenazando los
planes de la ONU como revela el presente
informe la inseguridad alimentaria se
deterioró todavía más en 2021 el único
Progreso realizado en relación con las
metas mundiales de nutrición para 2030
se registró en la lactancia materna
exclusiva en lactantes menores de seis
meses de edad y en el retraso del
crecimiento infantil
según la FAO la situación también se
verá afectada por la desaceleración de
las economías a nivel mundial en 2023 a
lo cual se le suman fenómenos
meteorológicos extremos así como la
esperada llegada del fenómeno del niño
en Estados Unidos el presidente Joe
biden se mostró optimista sobre la
aprobación del acuerdo para Elevar el
techo de la deuda un pacto al que llegó
junto con el líder de la cámara de
representantes el republicano kiabi
macarthy y tras dos semanas de
negociaciones y en el que acordaron
además recortes en programas sociales
ahora ambas partes deberán persuadir a
los legisladores de sus respectivos
partidos para que voten a favor del
proyecto antes del 5 de junio fecha en
la que el país podría caer en un posible
default
nunca digo que tenga confianza en lo que
el congreso va a hacer pero me siento
muy bien al respecto he hablado con
varios de los miembros hablé con
mcconnell hablé con mucha gente y se
siente bien veremos cuando comienza la
votación
hasta aquí este Informativo en France 24
gracias por acompañarnos los invitamos a
que continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]